We've talked before in the class about
aggravating circumstances and about those
being the reasons to
give the death penalty.
Uh,
we saw that the mandatory death
penalty statutes were struck down,
uh,
because there was no consideration of
the individual offender that was taken
into account.
The Supreme Court in 1976 in the cases
that we looked at back at that time,
uh,
the three that were upheld from Florida,
Georgia and Texas,
and the two that were struck
down from Earth Carolina,
Louisiana.
Uh,
the fatal problem with the North Carolina,
Louisiana statutes were that they did
not allow for consideration of the
individual person.
Uh,
the court upheld,
uh,
the Georgia and Florida statutes that
provided for mitigating circumstances.
Georgia statute just said
anything in mitigation.
Florida gave a long list of mitigating
factors and then Texas as three special
questions.
But the idea was that the,
the jury would be able
to take into account,
uh,
things about the person
when they decided that,
uh,
as the court said,
the diverse frailties of humankind,
this was in Woodson versus North Carolina,
uh,
was required.
Uh,
now,
normally,
uh,
the scope of sentencing and what
can come in at sensing is decided by
legislature.
So by statutes,
uh,
and non capital cases,
they decide,
for example,
in the federal system what is going
to be taken into account under the
sentencing guidelines.
Uh,
the question that comes before the United
States Supreme Court that we're going
to talk about today,
uh,
is now that we know there has to
be individualized consideration.
Uh,
how broad is that or how narrow is that?
A,
can the states decide,
uh,
what factors can be considered as
Florida did with its list of mitigating
factors?
And we're going to see where the
Ohio statute a very clear example,
uh,
of a limit on mitigation and then what
the Supreme Court says as a matter of
constitutional law.
In the case of a woman
named Sandra Lockett,
who was involved in a pawnshop robbery,
uh,
in Ohio,
if ever there was a sympathetic case,
if a murder case can ever be a sympathetic
case to come before the Supreme
Court,
uh,
it was Sandra lockets case.
Uh,
she was 21 years old.
She had no prior record
of any serious misconduct,
and she,
and a man named Al Parker,
Nathan road,
drew and her brother,
uh,
were involved in the
robbery of a pawn shop.
There was no plan to kill.
Uh,
but once the,
uh,
the people,
she's in the car a while the others go
in to rob the pawnbroker a pawnbroker.
Uh,
and while in there,
uh,
a fight breaks out and Parker
shoots and kills the pawn broker.
So he's the main person here in terms
of having committed the committed the
homicide.
Uh,
but he pleads,
he pleads guilty and testifies against
the other people in exchange for that,
he avoids the death pony.
This is your classic a plea bargaining,
uh,
in capital cases.
Lockets brother as tried
and sentenced to death,
uh,
and do a,
does not receive the death penalty because
it's found that his involvement was
primarily the product
of a mental deficiency.
That is a mental limitations.
A excused him from the death poem and
then Sandra Lockett was sentenced to
death.
Now let's take a look at the Ohio Statute,
uh,
and what it provided,
with regard to,
uh,
how the death penalty was
going to be imposed in Ohio.
A seven aggravating circumstances.
A person if one or more of those is
found than the death penalty is imposed
unless the jury finds,
uh,
one of the three mitigating factors,
one of them being that
the victim of the offense,
uh,
mmm,
induced or facilitated,
uh,
the crime.
Uh,
secondly that there was duress,
coercion or strong provocation involved.
Uh,
and finally,
and this is the one that applied to Mr Do,
uh,
that the offense was primarily the result
of the offenders psychosis or mental
deficiency.
None of these apply to Sandra Lockett.
Uh,
she's minimally involved.
She's out in the car while the
crime takes place in the pawn shop.
Uh,
she has some other factors,
uh,
that she wants to put forward,
which we'll talk about in a moment.
But what's Ohio trying to do here?
What Ohio is trying to do is follow what
the court said in the 1976 cases and
limit the consideration of aggravating
and mitigating circumstances.
So that it's the same in every case on
the theory that this will mean that the
death penalty will be
consistently imposed an Ohio,
uh,
the problem is it leaves
out considerations of some
fairly compelling mitigating
factors.
Ah,
what Sandra Lockett,
one of the court to hear.
Uh,
it was about her minor participation in
the crime and not only hear about it.
Of course,
they knew that,
uh,
from the,
from the trial,
uh,
but to take that into account,
as a mitigating factor,
uh,
as a reason not to give
her the death pony.
Uh,
she also had a testimony
of a psychologist,
uh,
that her prognosis for
rehabilitation was good,
uh,
that also she was in a drug treatment
program and she was on the road to
recovery.
Uh,
and,
uh,
these factors could not be taken
into account in deciding her sins.
And the judge,
uh,
seems to have some reluctance,
in imposing the death public.
Uh,
in this case,
Chief Justice Burger rights for the
court and he goes through at some length,
uh,
the plea bargaining,
the offer that was made to send
her lock at two weeks before trial.
Uh,
the offer that was made on the day of
trial and the offer that was made to her
to get a life sentence to plead guilty
and avoid the death penalty after Parker
testified at a trial.
Now,
normally settlement negotiations or plea
negotiations have no legal significance
whatsoever.
Uh,
but what Chief Justice Burger is clearly
communicating here is that the state
really didn't believe that it had to
have the death pony for Sandra Lockett.
It was willing to give her a plea bargain.
Uh,
and this is unusual and that all the
plea offers are set out in the Supreme
Court's opinion,
uh,
and brings,
the court to the conclusion,
uh,
in terms of what can be
considered a and a judge.
She says,
Burger writing for the court says that
the eighth and 14th amendment required
that the sensor in all but the very
rarest cases is not to be prevented from
considering as a mitigating factor,
any aspect,
uh,
of the life and background
and circumstances,
uh,
of the defendant as well of course
as the circumstances of the crime.
But any factors,
uh,
proffered by the defense as a
basis for sentence less than death,
uh,
failure to consider this,
he says,
we'll run the risk of the death
police being imposed despite,
uh,
factors that may cause for may
be rezoned for a lesser sentence.
Uh,
and therefore that would be arbitrary
under the eighth amendment that if someone
like Sandra Lockett is
receiving the death penalty,
even though they're factors that call,
uh,
for her to receive a lesser sins that
violates the eighth amendment's protection
against cruel and unusual punishment.
Uh,
whether there's not a
unanimity with regard to this,
a justice white,
uh,
it says this is,
we're just going right back to farming.
We're going back to completely unfettered
discretion by juries if they can
consider anything and then decide on the
death pony based on anything that's put
before them.
Uh,
we're right back to Fermin.
Interestingly,
uh,
when we looked at an
aggravating circumstances,
uh,
after the supreme court
decided Zant versus Stevens,
the case that said,
once the jury finds an aggravating factor,
it can consider anything and impose
whatever punishment it wants.
Justice Marshall had said,
we've gone back to Fermin.
So now we have justices on both
sides of the court who are saying,
we're,
we are risking now,
uh,
the arbitrary imposition of the death
pony that we found to be unconstitutional
in Furman versus Georgia.
This case could not be more important,
uh,
because,
what,
uh,
the Supreme Court is saying here is that,
the defendant,
the defense council decides
what's going to be admitted,
uh,
in,
mitigation in a,
in a case.
In other words,
the state can't decide that these three
mitigating factors like Ohio did are the
only three things to be account taken
into account or that the long list that
Florida had,
which was much more many
more mitigating factors.
Uh,
it,
it has to be not only those,
but anything that the defense proffers
as the basis for a sentence less than
death.
And as the death pony develops
after the Lockett case,
uh,
these,
become critical in terms of what evidence
is going to be admitted at the penalty
phase,
uh,
of capital case.
Um,
we see this applied again in the
case of a Eddings versus Oklahoma.
This is a 16 year old youth,
uh,
who was,
convicted and sentenced to death in
Oklahoma for the murder of a state
patrolman.
Uh,
he had three aggravating factors,
heinous,
atrocious and cruel,
avoiding arrest and future dangerousness.
Uh,
the trial judge admitted evidence,
uh,
of his trouble youth.
The fact that his parents divorced
when he was just five years old,
uh,
that his mother was an alcoholic,
probably a prostitute,
a,
that he was not supervised and that he
was excessively punished by his father.
All this evidence comes in,
but the judge,
and this was a sentencing not by a jury,
but by a judge.
The judge says that he
cannot take into account,
uh,
the facts of Eddings violent background.
Uh,
Supreme Court decides,
uh,
that that violates,
um,
lock it versus,
oh,
hi,
chief justice Berger who wrote,
lock it now to parts company
with a court and says,
wait a minute.
Uh,
this is just semantics.
the judge,
uh,
received all the evidence.
Uh,
Miss,
uh,
what he said,
shouldn't be a basis for setting aside
with the majority of the court said,
you've got to not only admit
the mitigating evidence,
but it has to be considered.
It has to be a part of
the weighing process,
which is what Oklahoma had a has to be
part of the weighing process in deciding
whether or not to give the death pelvic
and Hitchcock versus Dugger the Supreme
Court.
And one of the rare times in all of
its stuff pulling cases is unanimous,
nine to nothing,
uh,
with Justice Scalia writing for the court
and striking down a jury instruction
in Florida that limited the mitigating
circumstances to just the mitigating
those set out in the statute.
Uh,
this is,
uh,
we're going to see,
that this does not last long.
Uh,
the Justice Scalia and Justice Thomas,
they're going to part company with this,
but at least at this one time,
a 1987 when Hitchcock was decided this
was the one place where the court was in
complete agreement that anything about
the life and background and the person,
uh,
should be considered.
What about the Texas statute though?
Uh,
we recall that we,
when we looked at that when we talked
about aggravating circumstances,
uh,
Texas has these three special questions.
Uh,
was it deliberate?
is the person a future danger,
a probability that there'll
be a future danger?
Uh,
and was there provocation,
uh,
how is mitigating our,
how our mitigating factors
considered in the Texas,
uh,
scheme of,
the supreme court had
rejected a challenge,
uh,
in a case,
Franklin versus [inaudible],
uh,
in which he had wanted to put on
or said his evidence in mitigation,
which was as good behavior in prison,
uh,
could not be considered
under these three questions.
Uh,
but the supreme court said,
actually it could be considered a
under the questions and therefore,
uh,
because when you're looking
at future dangerousness,
one thing you could ask
and looking at that is,
has the person,
uh,
adjusted well to prison or jail,
in the past.
Uh,
so that was rejected,
but a very different cases
presented by John Paul penry.
Uh,
his mitigating factor is
his intellectual disability,
or at the time referred to in the
Supreme Court case as mental retardation.
Uh,
and he says that under the three,
uh,
Texas questions,
this cannot,
uh,
be considered,
justice O'Connor accepts that argument
for the court and says that evidence of
intellectual disability is
relevant to moral culpability,
uh,
so that the jury can express
what she often says in her cases,
a reasoned moral response,
uh,
to,
the crime and the defendants
that are before it.
Uh,
and she points out that this,
uh,
evidence of intellectual disability
could not be considered under the,
uh,
three questions that Texas has.
A,
it's not appropriate for deliberateness.
Uh,
it doesn't go to future dangerousness.
She points out,
it goes,
it cuts both ways because the person
who is intellectually disabled,
uh,
may not learn from their mistakes,
may not plan,
and therefore it may be a future
danger or it could be used by a jury to
conclude that they're a future danger.
And of course,
it doesn't go to provocation.
Uh,
the,
the last question that's asked,
uh,
here we see the court starting
to disagree about this.
Justice Scalia,
uh,
writes a descending opinion.
He's joined by justice
Rehnquist white and Kennedy.
So this is a five,
a to four opinion.
He says,
uh,
Texas has done a perfectly
fine job guiding the
discretion of the jury with the
three questions and we
should leave it alone.
Uh,
the Supreme Court has,
uh,
no,
business,
uh,
telling Texas how it is to consider a
mitigating factors is justice Scalia puts
it somewhat.
Carl flee,
uh,
this puts all sympathetic factors are
just to be dumped before the jury,
uh,
for an outpouring of personal reaction.
And of course what he's saying there
is this is going to be arbitrary too.
So the argument is one,
if you don't consider the
individual circumstances,
it will be arbitrary.
Uh,
but if you do allow anything to be
taken into account in mitigation,
the death planning is going
to be imposed a arbitrarily,
uh,
in two cases that came not long after
that 1990 Walton versus Arizona and in
1993 grand versus Collins,
uh,
Justice Scalia and justice Thomas reject
the Woodson lock at line of cases.
That is the cases that say that any
thing offered as a basis for a sentence,
less than death has to be
admitted in mitigation.
Uh,
Justice Scalia says in Walton
that there's an inherent tension,
uh,
between the requirements of aggregation
that limiting aggravating circumstances
and having unlimited
mitigating circumstances,
uh,
and that these contradictory commands,
does not constrain the discretion of
the jury in the way that it should be.
Uh,
and so his question,
and this is what I raised earlier,
whether society,
uh,
may specify what factors are going to
be taken into account in sentencing or
not.
And in other words,
could the state legislature decide,
as Ohio did,
these are the only three
mitigating factors or as Florida,
these are the mitigating factors,
uh,
that we're going to allow.
Uh,
as a result,
uh,
he decides that he will no longer follow,
the Woodson locket line of cases.
And so from now on,
Justice Scalia dissents from any case
involving a consideration of mitigating
circumstances where the court says there
was a unconstitutional limitation on
that.
Um,
the,
uh,
justice Thomas basically the same
thing in grand versus Collins.
He takes a different approach.
Says Fermin was a case
about racial discrimination,
uh,
points out that the power
to be lenient is also,
uh,
the power,
to discriminate a and says that
the state should be allowed,
uh,
to,
limit consideration or mitigating factors.
In fact,
in his opinion,
just as Thomas,
uh,
in Graham versus Collins makes it pretty
clear that he does not have any problem
with the mandatory death pony statutes.
Uh,
that saying that some crimes are so bad
that there always should be punished
with death.
Uh,
as far as he's concerned
is not violate anything.
Uh,
in the eighth amendment,
uh,
justice Stevens responds to both opinions.
Uh,
and he says four things.
First,
the death penalty is not
allowed for certain offenses,
uh,
that a number of a rape,
other,
uh,
non homicide cases are no longer even
considered eligible for the death point of
kidnapping,
armed robbery,
other,
other crimes like that.
Uh,
secondly,
the aggravating circumstances narrow the
class of people who can be considered
for the death.
Polly,
and this is what the eighth amendment
requires to narrow the class of people who
are eligible.
Uh,
he also says the vague and
overbroad aggravating circumstances,
um,
uh,
are,
are not allowed actually,
uh,
as,
as we discussed when we talked
about a aggravating factors,
uh,
the courts have said that those catch
all aggravating circumstances like
heinous,
atrocious and cruel,
uh,
can be considered as long as the state
supreme court gives them a limiting
instruction.
Uh,
so whether that's as great,
greater protection as,
as,
as he says in the opinion,
uh,
is,
is questionable.
Uh,
and finally,
uh,
that the consideration of whatever is
offered as a basis for a sentence less
than death,
it's consideration of mitigating
circumstances actually further narrows the
class because things like abuse,
mental illness,
in this case a intellectual disability.
Those are factors that may call for a
sentence less than death and do coffers
sentence less than death in
some cases such as penry.
And so once the death point has
been narrowed by the first three,
then the jury can consider in mitigation,
uh,
anything,
in,
in order to decide the ultimate
question of life and death.
Um,
finally I want to take a look at
a ton are versus a direct fee.
This was a case in which the courts have
both Texas and the United States Court
of Appeals for the fifth circuit
had limited mitigating factors.
One limitation they had put on it was
to say that mitigating factors had to be
uniquely severe.
These are a number of cases that came
back after the penry decision in which
Texas had to decide,
um,
whether or not the Texas
Court of criminal appeals.
And ultimately the United States Court
of Appeals for the fifth circuit had to
decide whether to Nard and others were
entitled a new sentencing hearings
because evidence of their
mental limitations or
intellectual disability was not
admitted.
Uh,
both courts,
a Texas Court of criminal appeals,
uh,
said we find no evidence that,
tonight is a mentally retarded.
So therefore there is no
constitutional violation.
In his case,
uh,
the United States Court of Appeals,
the fifth circuit said this was not a,
uh,
uniquely severe and permanent handicap,
which burdened the defendant through no
fault of his own and therefore there was
no problem.
Uh,
the other,
uh,
limitation,
was the notion that there had to be a
nexus between the mitigating factor and
the crime.
In other words,
the Texas Court of Criminal Appeals
said no evidence that his low Iq and to
nards case prevented him from appreciating
the wrongfulness of his conduct,
uh,
and kept him from,
controlling his impulses
when this crime took place.
Uh,
and again,
the fifth circuit said
when it looked at the case,
uh,
there was no evidence that showed that
the crime was attributable to his low Iq.
Uh,
Supreme Court rejects that,
uh,
s six to three,
with justice O'Connor writing
a for a majority of the court.
She's joined by Steven's Kennedy,
Souter,
Ginsburg and Bryer.
And she said these tests that the
court in Texas had applied and that the
federal court had applied has no basis,
no foundation in the decisions
of the Supreme Court.
That there's no screening that's
done by a judge or by a court,
uh,
before evidence in has offered to see
if it's uniquely severe or if there's a
nexus between it.
Uh,
and the,
uh,
the crime that was
committed that she repeats,
that,
uh,
mitigation has been very broadly defined,
says that a low Iq is
inherently mitigating,
even if it doesn't amount
to a mental retardation,
which would preclude the death penalty.
It may still be a compelling mitigating
factor if the person has limited
intellectual functioning.
Uh,
she says the court has spoken
in the most expansive terms,
uh,
and defining mitigation that
irrelevant mitigation is evidence,
which tends to prove some
fact or circumstance,
which,
uh,
would be,
which a fact finder that is the jury
would find had mitigating value.
Uh,
chief justice Rehnquist
Scalia and Thomas dissent.
Uh,
but this is basically,
uh,
the,
state of the law today,
uh,
that the,
this prevailing view that,
uh,
anything offered in the lie about the
life and background of the defendant that
seen as a basis for a sentence less than
death can be considered in mitigating
in mitigation.
Uh,
we will talk next with Susan Marcus,
who has done a lot of work both in
investigating and finding mitigating
circumstances and also as a
lawyer in presenting it to juries.